your business is wasting time and money
performing routine repetitive tasks that
could easily be automated to increase
speed and efficiency robotic process
automation was made for this it's a
low-res tool that speeds up routine
tasks freeing your employees to do
higher value work our PA has many
advantages but it can't automate entire
business processes or workflows on its
own
for instance what happens when a person
needs to be involved stand alone our PA
can't automate complex processes end to
end because humans and BOTS aren't
working together what happens if you
need to change business rules on the fly
with only our PA rule changes often
require an expensive redeployment that
could take weeks and even though our PA
makes copying and pasting data faster
and eliminates human error what happens
when it encounters unstructured data and
can't organize and store captured data
so your users can find it our PA alone
is no substitute for a purpose-built
fully automated process but when our PA
integrates with other automation
software it's much more effective IBM
our PA with automation anywhere is
bundled with digital business automation
Express a set of digital business
automation tools that give you the extra
capabilities you need when our PA alone
isn't getting the job done like workflow
capabilities that helps humans and
automation coordinate to run complex
processes from start to finish
operational decision management
capabilities that give you the agility
to change rules on the fly with no
downtime automated capture capabilities
that can understand any source including
unstructured data and intelligent
content management capabilities that
help users and BOTS locate and access
data faster get everything you're
looking for in a robotic process
automation solution plus the additional
automation capabilities you need to
unlock greater value from our PA
IBM robotic process automation with
automation anywhere learn more today